so when Microsoft first got started I
wrote mostly code and everybody else's
code I read and kind of rewrote and that
got us up to ten people how do you build
the plane to delegate and build a
massive Empire and make your mission
happen here we go
entrepreneurs somebody who is greater
conceiving ideas starting ideas building
ideas but then handing over to really
good managers to manage the businesses
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it's Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message learn to delegate
over to you Bill Gates also if you want
to hear what Bill Gates and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building confidence check out my
250 for confidence series yes I believe
in the internet I believe it'll get
increasingly popular and we're doing
some neat new things to take advantage
of that every day for the next 254 days
I will send you a 30 second to five
minute video for free every morning to
help you build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description below
you want to have impact usually
delegation is important although you
know individual contributors in terms of
inventing a drug or a new approach to
things that's phenomenal
so when Microsoft first got started I
wrote most of code and everybody else's
code I read and kind of rewrote and that
got us up to ten people and then I had
to say to myself okay we were gonna ship
code that I didn't edit and that was
hard for me but you know I kind of got
over that then I still said okay I'm
gonna interview everyone and I mean at
least look at samples of their code well
that got us up to about 40 people and
that was at a point where I had sold way
more software than we could write
because everybody was so impressed and I
thought well I need to keep enough
collect enough money to you know keep
hiring all these people but the demand
was so high that you know we were
actually falling behind that's when I
hired Steve and Steve figured out a how
to control what promises I made to
people and B how to hire lots of people
and good really good people and create
organizations and teams so I delegated
to Steve that and he was constantly
saying to me okay we're gonna hire
programmers that you've never met and
I'd say no or not and then he would show
me numerically that the constraint
wasn't gonna work you know so then I
said okay then I would you know know all
the managers of the people and so over
time and of course you know I could say
the quality per person was falling
monotonically
according to me but you know large
problems if you want to know right the
most popular office productivity
software that one person can't do that
you can write pretty code so everyone
has to decide what scale of organization
they want to work in eventually you know
my role was very much as a leader and a
reviewer of managers but the top people
and I hired some super experienced
people I would make sure they were
pursuing a common vision and they were
well coordinated but in terms of a lot
of management stuff they were way better
than I was and I had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of you know my value Adam was
picking say to do graphic user interface
or to do an integrated office type thing
or to go global and not use agents to
have Microsoft be present all over the
world and so yeah picking what you're
good at and how you find the other
people to fill in those things that's
super important and most founders don't
aren't able to scale that up and kind of
give up the hands-on things that they
used to get a lot of pleasure and
comfort from you can't do this alone
you cannot Kapil your purpose your
mission alone if you are a one-man Bain
forever you will always stay small I
like to say in this channel that you
have Michael Jordan level talent at
something and I want you to find it
embrace it use it make a difference
Michael Jordan can't win an NBA
championship on his own if he's going
1v5 no matter how great Michael Jordan
is he will lose an average NBA team will
beat Michael Jordan on his own and
that's the problem you might be a star
at what you do but if you try to go it
alone you won't get nearly as far you
won't end up winning and so it's
figuring out what are you great at what
can you be Michael Jordan at and then
learning to bring people on to take on
some of those tasks because of all the
work that has to get done in the
business of all the work that you do if
you're a solo entrepreneur you're doing
everything yourself
you're everything from the the
CEO down to the janitor 90% of that work
you should not Altima be doing you
should not be ultimately the janitor in
your business right unless you have
Michael Jordan level talent at
janitorial things and go build a
janitorial business you should be doing
most of the things that you're doing
what you have Michael Jordan level
talent and abilities at what you could
be among the best in the world at is not
100 percent of what you're doing right
now it's five to ten percent of what
you're doing and you need to turn that
five to ten percent into your 8090
percent that's when you ultimately win
and the only way to do it is to delegate
the rest of the stuff to other people
and allow them to be the Michael
Jordan's or the Scottie Pippen's of
those things at the beginning it's
really hard it sucks it's difficult you
you don't know how to hire people you've
never managed something before it's very
rare that the first hire at a company is
still around years later not because
that that person sucked is because the
owner sucked the entrepreneur suck they
didn't know how to hire people they know
how to train people they don't know how
to delegate properly and so the person
ends up leaving but that's part of the
growing pains you can work on yourself
you can learn work on leadership you can
work on management you can work on
inspiring people and getting to know
them and understanding them and being a
better manager you can work on all that
and you need to if you're gonna build
something substantial now it just
depends on your ambition if you want to
run a business by yourself and have it
have an OK income and just coast that's
your lifestyle awesome but if your
mission driven you want to have a big
impact on the world you you need other
people it's a necessity you cannot just
do this by yourself and so it's really
hard when you have a lot of talents at
something and the people coming in
aren't as good as you potentially it's
really hard when the first person that
you hire or the second person the third
person and they don't all work out it's
super common for you to hire one person
doesn't work out say wow this sucks I
knew this wasn't gonna work and you go
back to doing everything yourself
like expecting the first girl that you
kiss to be your wife right the first
girl that you hold hands with or a scout
and the data is gonna be the one that
you marry is ridiculous that happens
sometimes very rarely but it's
ridiculous to expect that every single
time and it's mostly because you don't
know yourself enough and you haven't
developed the leadership skills yet so
how do you do it how do you move from
being a solo entrepreneur and trying to
do everything yourself or having maybe a
few people under you to at
building something that you can be proud
of beyond the mindset mindset is always
the first step mindset is I cannot do
everything myself I need to delegate I
need to be able to build a team because
I know that I can only take it so far
having the humility and the ego right
that the ego the confidence like I'm
great
I could be Michael Jordan or something
and the humility to know that I can't do
everything myself
and looking at my channel that's what I
that's what I did at the beginning I did
everything I was in front of the camera
behind the camera doing the research
doing the scripts everything all of it
100% me and I mean one video a week my
best skill is being in front of the
camera my best skills be able to review
the content and say this and not this
and this or not this because I need
everything that go through have the lens
of believe on top of it but now that I
have eight people on my team I can make
three videos a day you can see the
growth of my channel explode as I
brought on more people because they did
work that they loved and I got to do
more work that I love by delegating some
of the tasks away even if maybe at the
beginning that was better at doing that
job than they were I had to train them
to do a better job but it was worth it
because it allows me to do what only I
can do that's a lot harder the teaching
train you can't train the soul of Evan
Carmichael right you can't train the
soul of belief what I do for me my
interpretation everything that is me
cannot be given to somebody else pieces
for sure but what I do my energy my
message my truth I can't have anybody
come up and tell me tell you my truth
Bill Gates might be have his story Eric
Thomas might be a better speaker than me
all these people can come in but they
can't tell my truth the way that I can
that's why I need to go all in on so the
steps how do you do it how do you build
the plane to delegate and build a
massive Empire and make your mission
happen here we go
step number one write down your list of
weekly tasks write down everything that
you do in a week anything it takes more
than 15 minutes every week write that
down on a piece of paper or an Excel
spreadsheet or Word document whatever
everything that takes more than 15
minutes you're gonna write down in the
week from from Saturday to Friday write
all the way through anything
business-related you're gonna write down
on that list
step number two is you're gonna circle
everything on that list that you feel
that you have Michael Jordan level
talent at you may not be there yet but
you want to develop it like that day
that thing that I do here I love doing
that I want to develop my skills there I
want to be among the best in the world
of those things circle those things from
all the tasks that you're doing during
the week however many circles you have
three circles five circles if you're
circling most of the stuff then you're
not doing a great job like you don't
want to be the world's best email
manager an accountant and salesperson
and researcher aimed front person for a
camera right and marketer like you don't
want to be the best at everything like
get real honest with yourself big pick
three things maximum of all those things
that you spend more than 15 minutes
three things maximum you're gonna do a
circle around that gives you the
awareness of here's all the tasks that
have to get done in my business and
here's what I want to focus on ideally
everything else should be delegated now
you're not gonna go from no team to ten
people on your team right that's that's
silly even if you got money that's silly
because you don't know how you don't
know how to manage ten people you're
gonna you're gonna drown yourself in
just administration and leadership
issues and management cuz you're not
good at it yet that's okay
so you have your tasks of the things you
spend more than 15 minutes on you've
circled the three that you love pick one
thing on that list you might have a
hundred things on that list pick one and
get rid of it this week delegate it to
somebody else the first person I hired
for my first business I hired for one
hour a day to work on my company doing
database entry stuff and that freed up
an hour and a half of my time because he
was actually better at it than I was to
the focus on growing my business the
first version you hire doesn't have to
be a full-time employee and in fact it's
better it's not whether you end up
hiring a local friend somebody in your
city a family member somebody on one of
the job boards upwork.com I'm a big fan
of wherever you're getting that person
practice this week take one thing on
that list and give it to somebody else
to do and then every week you just take
one more task one more task one more
task take it away from you stretch the
amount of time you're spending on the
things that you love doing be the
delegator be the leader and go crush
your mission now have a really special
bonus clip that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question of the
day I want to know what is that one
thing that you're gonna give up this
week seven days from today you're gonna
give up one task on that list what does
that pass that you will give up to
somebody else delegate it away leave in
the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
the next stage is you know is to be a
great delegator and not try to do
everything yourself try to find people
who are better than you all the time try
to find people are better than you to
put you put you out of business
effectively so you know whatever you're
spending all your day doing try to find
someone who's better than you to do that
to replace you at it so that you know
you can go off and you know think about
the next big picture you know an
entrepreneur is not a man I'm not a
manager I mean an entrepreneur somebody
who is greater conceiving ideas starting
and starting ideas built building ideas
but then handing over to really good
managers to manage the businesses you
know the moment you've got more than one
business you can't be hands-on doing
everything great entrepreneurs are able
to delegate the successful women CEOs
are remarkably good at this remarkably
good at it and the way it works is Sara
give I'll give you an example the way
Sara works she hires somebody she sets a
goal for 90 days and gets out of their
way gets completely out of their way
lets them achieve it if they achieve it
she moves them up the organization if
they don't they get three tries until
they're out if you can't achieve your
goals in business that's what happens
but her whole thing is let them do the
work themselves let them figure it out I
don't want to use my time for it that's
what I hired them for raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
value is that passion not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your that's
something to me I don't ever give up I'd
have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details